(audience applauding and cheering)
- You had some oohs and awes.
People are excited about this book.
I'm just saying. I'm just saying.
- That's good. Go get it.
- I know, exactly.
How are the holidays going for you?
- They're going great.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- Yeah, I like this time of year.
- [Kelly] Me, too.
- And I know you like the spirit.
- I love it.
But I hear this about you, too.
You played football, right?
- [Mark] As far as I know.
- Yes, you did.
(audience laughing)
You definitely did, I Googled it
because I recently got into football.
I, like, hardcore crazy. Like, I'm cr-
Look at you.
(audience applauding and cheering)
I love it.
Did you love it? Did you love playing?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
Do you watch religiously like me now?
- I watch, I don't have
a team I follow, really.
- Really?
- Yeah.
But I have players I follow.
- Oh, I like that.
- Yeah, like, maybe you meet someone
or maybe someone's a guest on your show
and all of a sudden you go...
- Yeah.
- Hey, Troy Aikman, right?
- Yeah. Well, I'm Texan, so Cowboys. Yeah.
- That's why I said Troy Aikman.
- Nicely done. Nicely done.
(Mark laughing)
Yeah, I was like, I've been
following him for a minute.
- But if you meet Troy
Aikman and I meet him
'cause he's a UCLA guy and so am I,
but every once in a while,
they'll have a quarterback,
like a gathering, right?
- Yeah.
- So you go, and I don't
go to a lot of them,
but when you go and Troy is there.
- Yeah.
- Troy's a monster.
- I mean,
Troy is like, 6'6" and like-
- And really good at football.
- Really good at football
and big legs and big body
and hands that could encompass
your whole head, right?
And so when I played, we were
a bunch of little option,
triple option guys, you
know, like, six feet guys
that would run around do a
whole different offense, yeah.
- Oh my gosh. Do you
get into fantasy at all?
Fantasy football?
- Yeah, I'm glad you
said fantasy football.
That was, like, the whole thing.
(audience laughing)
- Both are acceptable.
- I got it, I got it.
- No, I-
- Both are fun.
- I love that you do it.
- No, because you like players.
That's what I'm saying. Like-
- I like players, but I don't
like 'em like that, yeah.
- I know, but you know what?
It opened my eyes to other players.
It opened my-
Now I follow them and I get mad at them,
but I follow them more
so than just my team.
It's kind of interesting.
- Have you ever met any of 'em?
- Yes, I hosted the
NFL Honors, so I'm met-
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- So sometimes it's cool,
sometimes not so cool?
Well, I think, Dak was probably like,
man, can you lay off me?
(laughs) 'Cause he's a Cowboys player
and I gave my team more crap than anyone.
- I get it.
- Because you have to.
And also, I want to go
to the Super Bowl, so.
- [Mark] I bet you
could do that, you know?
- I can't, but yeah.
- Your team might not
be, but you could go.
- My team, he's been doing,
he did really well this past-
I'm just saying, you could
maybe get into fantasy football.
It's really fun.
- No.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
He said hard no.
I'll do another team
for you, another league,
and I'll also call it Mark Harmon's.
I heard that you took, at
UCLA, you took a jazz class.
Like about jazz, like the history of it?
- You know how, sometimes-
- Jazz is hard for me.
- Well, yeah, at the time it
was called History of Jazz.
And I was a football player,
so that was thought of as a "mick", okay?
- A mick.
- A Mickey Mouse class, right?
- Wait, what?
- Okay, no.
It's like a class with 600 people in it.
They don't take attendance, so you can...
- Oh, a bird course, you
fly right through it.
- Same kind of thing.
- Ah, oh, bird course. Okay.
- Mick, bird course, same thing.
- Okay. And now I'm gonna use yours, okay.
- Okay, yeah, and anyway, I
find myself in that class.
But this guy's name was Paul Tanner,
and he was a jazz musician and he played
in the Dixieland Quartet
at Disneyland every summer.
- Oh, wow.
- But he's one of those
guys for me, just for me
in my college experience,
that's a special one.
And I got a chance to tell
him that before he passed.
And he was a gift.
I mean, I've never forgotten him.
- You have certain teachers
that move you, that open up-
- Well, he moved me, but I
wasn't supposed to be in there
in the first place, right?
So it was a mick.
A bird thing.
- Bird course, yeah.
Fly right through it.
I'm gonna use Mickey Mouse though now.
Yeah.
- Mickey Mouse.
It seems a little more fun.
- I don't know how you get
there with Mickey Mouse,
but I'm gonna ask in the commercial break.
So a couple of your older
projects have gotten new life.
I don't know if you know this, but we hear
that there's a potential
"Freaky Friday" sequel
and "Summer School" is blowing up online.
Like, did you expect that 35 years later?
It's all blowing up.
Like, people are wanting the sequel
and now they're talking about this again.
- Well, the first one is because
Jamie's talking about it.
- Yeah.
- And you know Jamie.
- Yeah, I love Jamie.
- Right? I do too.
And I've known her since she was 15, so.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- If she's talking about
it, then it'll happen.
- [Kelly] It's probably gonna happen.
- 'Cause all things happen.
- Yes.
Did you ever expect the other one, though?
Summer life for 35 years later?
- "Summer School?
- Yeah "Summer School," sorry.
- No, no, yeah.
I was just so thrilled that Carl Reiner
was interested in me to play this part.
And then my wife read the
script at the same time,
said, "don't go near this. Don't do this."
But we have very different
opinions of material
and things like that, which is healthy.
But I just said, "he thinks I can do this.
So I'm gonna do it."
- Yeah.
- So I went and did it.
- I love that.
- And all those kids...
(audience applauding)
- But I love that it's
like blowing back up.
I just think it's cool
when it comes back around.
It's like music.
People like, I hear young
kids talking about music-
- [Mark] Yeah, great soundtrack.
- I'm like, that's like from the '70s.
Like, what? Yeah.
- And all those people were young
and just starting out at that time, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So those kids were all over 30
when they were playing high school kids.
- Of course.
- Everyone of them had an
idea after every scene,
"Hey, Carl, hey Carl,
hey Carl, can I do this?"
And he'd go, "ha, ha, ha, no."
- No.
(audience laughing)
- Like, okay.
- Stick to it.
- Yeah, but so many of the little threads
at the end of every scene
that he let the camera
roll on are in that film.
- [Kelly] Oh, cool.
- And I had a chance to
work with him later years
laying down a track for
the movie years later
and a chance to sit with him
for four hours and do that
and I loved that opportunity
to finally tell him what he meant to me.
- Oh, that's so cool.
- Yep.
- Yeah, you like to tell people that.
I like that about you so far in this.
That you like to let people know
that they like made a change
and an impact in your life.
That's cool.
- I was telling you that on the way out.
- Well, nobody, not
everybody does that. Yeah.
- Why?
- I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe they feel foolish or whatever-
- [Mark] You do that all the time.
- I do. Well, I'm a very
chatty person in general,
so I tell everybody everything.
- No, but there's a kindness in that.
It's not just being a chatty person.
- Yeah. It makes me feel
good to tell someone
that they've made a
big impact on me. Yeah.
What about "NCIS"?
Like, this show is ingrained in us.
It was in my household
for so long, like...
- Mine too.
- I know.
(audience laughing)
I know, but like, just
saying goodbye to that,
it's been a couple years
now, so what do you feel now?
Do you miss it?
- I think for the longest
time I was just tired.
- It's long hours.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Originally part of it, taking the job,
being home for a young
family, not traveling as much,
doing movies and whatever.
The first day we worked
22 hours, so I thought,
that's not exactly what I
thought this was gonna be,
but there were, we had
a lot of days like that
in the first four years.
- Oh, yikes.
- So, that it's been the success
it's become, that's great.
To be part of that is great.
You know, writers change,
runners change, casts change,
all that and I always tried
to pay attention to that
and daily tried to do what
my title said, which is,
you know, read ahead and note ahead
and do all those kind of things.
And it's a lot, you know?
And again, I paid attention
in the writing room, so.
- Yeah, which is important.
That's the story.
- Yeah, and that that was
successful, I'm proud of,
and the people who are part of that.
It's how I met Leon Carroll
who I ended up writing the book with,
and I wouldn't trade that
relationship with anyone.
So I'm proud of it in a different way.
- I love that this relationship
carried over with Leon
as well because you ended
up co-authoring this book.
- I did.
- And you worked with him on NCIS?
- He's a really gen, right?
- And in the be beginning, Kelly,
I tried to look up NCIS.
I'd never heard of it.
- I'd never heard of it before your show.
- Okay, you know about
it because of the show.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- But it had been around for
a long time. Long, long time.
- Yeah.
- Okay?
And, and the reason you
didn't know about it
is because these people doing this work,
it's really difficult work
and they do their job better
if no one knows about it.
That's really why, okay?
- Oh, wow.
- So then there's a TV show
and I'm trying to figure
out how to play a character,
so I'm trying to ask questions of someone
who knows even what it is, right?
And I meet Leon Carroll and he's my guy.
I mean, he's the real deal.
He's a real special agent, okay?
I'm an actor.
- Yeah.
- Big difference.
(audience laughing)
Big difference.
But over the years, there was
ever never an interrogation
on that show that I ever did
without talking to him first
and asking him about how he would do it.
What's the right way to do that?
You know, how to put
on a pair of handcuffs.
Whatever it was,
there were a thousand
things I had a day with him.
- Yeah, to get it right.
- But in over 20 years,
over 19 years, we developed a bond
and this show was originally
based on real cases originally,
and then things changed, like I said.
And so when this book opportunity
happened, it was like,
if we could tell real
stories of the agency,
and the first story is this book, "Ghost."
And it's a combined
authorship of the two of us
that we just thought there
was a story worth telling
and the people you're asking
and talking to about this,
they've never been asked
to talk about it before.
- Y'all should start a podcast,
too, is all I'm saying.
This is ama-
Well, Mark's co-author, Leon Carroll,
is in our audience right now.
So I need to ask, though, was
Mark, was he a good student?
Like, he's up here being like,
I had to learn how to hold handcuffs.
I had to learn how to-
How was he really?
- Mark was the best student around.
- [Kelly] Oh wow. Okay.
- He wanted to know all
the intricate things
about law enforcement and it was great.
- [Kelly] Inquisitive.
- But the most important thing
on set, he was a prankster.
Every night, I'd come
home with the cookies
that I had taken from
the craft service table,
reach into my pocket,
and now I bring up rusty bolts and nails.
(audience laughing)
So you knew you were loved that day.
- Oh, I love that.
Wait, so describe the
new book for everyone.
"Ghost of Honolulu."
- "Ghost of Honolulu," it's really about
the birth of the agency
back, Pearl Harbor.
And a special agent named
Doug Wada, Douglas Wada.
And it's really his story
and really the story
and birth of the agency.
So it's something we're proud of.
We worked really hard on it,
and I'm proud of my partner.
- Oh man, that's so cool.
(audience applauding and cheering)
I love that y'all are doing this
because it's creative,
but it's also informative,
which is my favorite kind of learning.
We need another break, though.
But Mark's book is called
"Ghost of Honolulu."
It's out now.
Well, Mark and Leon's book.
Everyone in our audience
is getting a copy.
- [Audience Member] Woo!
- Yeah, oh.
(audience cheering)
She just won a car.